[Music]
welcome back everybody
to Mike Mike Mike mik a great episode of
the careful boys where today we've got
Bart we've got Nick wo we got Steve we
got Jo look at the guns bro hey you got
some you got they're going dude that's a
big that's a bazooka we're working it
baby dude and we've got me
thank you thank you anybody else see
your
bicep see this gu is too big man you
guys put me in between Jared and Mike
the other day I can't do this right here
see start with him start with him oh
[__] damn oh [__] oh yeah I'm not going
I'm not going Emoji that's like the
Emoji I'm not going real gun I know but
you just had Jared and Michael they're
little PR I got a water gun dude that's
still nice dude that's pretty good we're
working give us two more years okay I
don't have B BPS but I lift more than
you how do you
know prove it I bench a lot sick I
believe you Joe Joe's a powerful guy
he's a he's a tyrannical dictator
Anthony versus Joe LIF Theon let's do
that dude we going do entire athleticism
Fitness track Let's do let's do a JK
athletic challeng Olympics I want to do
that I curl 50s [__] he does though he
does though bro look at those buys I
don't doubt it [__] I can roll
50 I'm good at Halo top right here is
inspired by my boy Mike all right I see
you've been doing even though you didn't
do it today which I'm a little bit sad
but you've been doing [__] new shoes
every day I was doing new shoes every
day was what is new shoes every day so I
I've been into shoes my whole life new
you have 365 days worth of shoes no but
I do have a lot and I feel bad because
uh I grew up like middle middle class
middle lower class but my dad was pretty
strict so like hey you buy these shoes
[__] take care of them and I do like
that yeah and he' maybe buy me a couple
pairs but when I was real young you'd
buy me one pair a year you know so I
have like this stuck in mentality to not
like crease them not [__] them up and
it's not cuz of the Jordan [__] and I
don't buy crazy expensive stuff but it's
just I feel bad making my [__] dirty
yeah so I have this huge collection I
never wear so I'm like how do I force
myself to wear them and I was doing a
new shoe a day but then I travel oh okay
so you got to take your shoes when I
travel I put on Paws cuz I was on a
10day trip I'm not bringing 10 pairs
yeah I'm not Britney Spear girls do they
do they really do they're also smaller
though that's true and when I'm so I'm
at home yeah I'm doing it I I'll pick it
back up Monday okay yeah do you have a
whole bedroom of just shoes I have a
pretty big walk-in closet and like half
the wall of shoes wow wow got to
estimate how many shoes you had that's
why I was trying to do this day thing 30
probably like 50 have you seen Patrick
mahomes's closet yeah some of those guys
are my God have you seen Caro Anthony's
closet some they literally like a
museum if you're sponsored by Jord you
have a museum I probably got like 20
shoes but I only wear one pair see I get
myself caught up in that yeah and I'll
wear like four pairs on rotation I've
got I maybe got 30 yeah might have 30 to
50 I'm probably like 15 I don't got the
woo on one baby I don't even have
special shoes I just don't wear it yeah
yeah I ain't got the woo ones all right
so now we got a shoe connoisseur here
yeah all right a shoe Somali like the
sneakers I like them but I also like I'm
I'm so stupid and weird sometimes that
like I'll get like bunch of that shoes
and then I'll just still be a Chinese
boy and stick to like the basic simple
thing I just put on every day that's
what I'm saying I wear SAS every day
that's what I'm saying it's just easier
matches a bunch of [__] indoor soccer
shoes I got random [__] that I think is
going to flex and there's nothing I'm
going to do with it same and I don't do
anything I go to work like I and I work
at my gym I wear sandals yes okay so
because our connoisseur is here what
types of shoes say something about a
person yeah what does it say they're are
a lot of like very specifics let's start
with Crocs like even stereotypes Crocs
nowadays are just so generic hey you're
almost you're almost you're almost a Bas
[__] almost what's the water everyone's
drinking uh G has Tumbl the Stanley yeah
Stanley Tumbl yeah if you got a Stanley
and that those are sick I don't even oh
the the old school V what you that's I
got fired from Zoomies those are lesbian
sandals dude those Crocs are kind of hot
you don't like Crocs in general I I'm
actually an anti Croc are those Crocs
those are croc these are Crocs my boy
really they're Croc clogs I think if you
go I have Crocs but these are Barts can
I say something Crocs to me are the most
comfortable most functional shoe I do
like clogs clogs are coming back in a
lot of forms and I do like a little clog
game like the clog B Birkenstocks
sometimes
they're my feet I have very flat feet
and Crocs are the only shoes that give
me no pain no Arch pain yeah they're the
only one even like flat shoes what about
some Vans or I even got the Vivo be
flets yeah I would get planter fasciitis
like a [__] mother but my Crocs only
things that don't [__] me up that sucks
we're not talking science here we just
want to talk stereotypes and judgment
yeah I think at thiss are so popular
they are they're kind of basic bit Air
Force Ones yeah those That's a classic
it depends on what you rock it with
though cuz there's people that rock it
as if they have completely out of touch
with fashion and there's people that
rock like they're bringing it back and
they know how to rock it Air Force Ones
is my all-time favorite shoe but my feet
are too [__] wide so they CH you know
what you want to try you might want to
try a Croc no I do skater shoes actually
try a Croc just try a Croc just try a
Croc and the kids make fun of me a lot
too you like New Balance New Balance
one's hot and then two like super comfy
if you got a wide foot I got a pretty
wide foot what do you think about people
that wear
reok I was sponsored by rebok for a long
time and sadly yeah they're from a
fitness Point uh from both from both
fashionably they have like some Club C's
which are kind of like a Vans looking
thing but in 2023 is yeah the club Seas
though the club Seas you could wear uh
they literally look like a van or like a
Soma what do you think of kids kids are
probably on the come up what are clean I
have those those are like their SAS
you're old school B boy yeah yeah it
foreshadowed me getting with Hannah cuz
there's a British flag on this [__]
those are clean W that's love that's
love the cool thing about of for 5 years
yeah I have a pair of those
rock those are clean yeah the Air Force
Ones came back but growing up like the
Air Force One was like the gangster [__]
that's why I love it I grew up playing
basketball and whatever but I I never
wore Air Force Ones I couldn't afford
them there's lines you don't cross you
know and that was one of them I never
crossed what about black Air Force One
yeah that's it so I was even wearing
like even within Jordan right there's
like the famous 23s 1 to 23 each year he
played and then now they have 38 or some
[__] what do you think what do you think
about people that wear New Balance I'm a
huge New Balance guy I wear a lot of
like Dad shoes running shoes are
obviously what's in fashion so a lot of
guys wearing New Balance but even like
within each Jordan number there's almost
like stereotypes like I was wearing the
Jordan eight the other day which aren't
as popular and I had a really cool
collab version I'm wearing around
undefeated ones yeah and everyone in my
gyms call me like the thug Stompers and
like the all this stuff and I was like
dude like I get it you know people will
love wearing these yeah yeah Timberlands
are like a huge people love wearing
those hokas the [__] bro hocas
is that a Chinese shoe I don't know hok
is a running shoe that's turned pretty
lifestyle High fashiony cuz of the dad
in The Last 3 years the most functional
Niche shoe has now become the street
wear casual shoe which I felt like that
was the Asian Aunt shoe yeah or the N
Sho all over people are floating off the
like I ran my first marathon with those
and they were Marathon shoes and then
now they have a whole lifestyle division
with like tan tone colors it's seen
these are comfy they do look cool a lot
of it's honestly because of Kanye Kanye
kind of made the dad Sho super cool
right all Yeezys are basically New Age
dad shoes you know what's crazy you know
our [__] shooting tactical Solomon
shoes Solomon are making a street where
huge W Solomon yeah isn't that crazy
they're hug there were our tactical
Republican right proud bright shoe and
now the most what that hand doing watch
that hand the most liberal [__]
are wearing them to be fashion
heart [__] rightwing like straight up
Workman [__] and then all these liberal
hipsters are wearing it car heart's got
work in progress car Whip and that's
just like the high fashioned street but
it's crazy that like proud racist stuff
is now being adopted by
liberals there's Nazi [__] you know
Sho boss Hugo Boss ad whatever gu Black
Rifle Coffee Company my buddy founded
that thing and now Joe Rogan's wearing
he's a super liberal and [__] but the
Liberals don't accept they don't claim
them the Liberals don't claim them
Hollywood dude straight Libs all right
what what else what other stereotypical
dunks oh yeah what about panda dunks
Panda dunks are like like the low
hanging fruit that you have fash how
come people hate them so much yeah what
they're so common it's cuz they became
so common dunks got really cool because
they started doing a [__] ton of collabs
like when we were in high school and so
they did really cool collabs and they're
like kind of the rare boy sneaker then
they come out with the black and white
and black and White's always fashionable
everyone buys them and then they just
keep you know Nikes making cash so they
just keep revamping and revamping so
everyone wears dunks it's like uh you
know the term try hard Mr Halo would
know the term try hard I don't know that
term so try hard is just like a so if
you wear dunks you're kind of a tryhard
yeah kind of like it's like it's poser I
guess would be another term kind of like
I'm into fashion but I'm not and so
you're not actually culture vulture I
got white dunks with the black swish
that's it and I only wore them once to
go eat and then for some reason I just
can't compel myself to put them on
because I just see so many people
wearing dunks and I'm like you to wear
the play they're they're kind of like a
wider based air oh I like that and
they're skate shoe yeah they're a skate
shoe actually like they're wide super
basic and they're very comfortable they
look kind of like Air Force but wide
because it's uh skate Sho kids when I
went to V Beach a bunch and I was
wearing skate shoes cuz my feet are wide
like what airw walks or something
Genesis uh I was wearing Osiris no the
dks okay yeah yeah or DC DC thank you
and then these kids come up I'm not cool
these kids come up to me and they're
like they're like do you skate and I'm
like no and they're why you wear a skate
shoes and they all like like high I'm
like yeah that's a good point hello my
stinky viewers now I know what you're
thinking why you just call me Stinky
well today's video is brought to you by
Lumi and if you're out there in the
holidays sweating from stress oh no I
don't want to go to my family gathering
because they're going to smell me and go
I don't like sitting next to him he
stinks like like garbage well good thing
I'm here to share with you the awesome
MAA Lumi wholebody deodorant with this
amazing starter kit you get this
wonderful deodorant it's designed and
made by a
OBGYN if you don't know what that is
that's a [__] doctor and the design was
specifically made
for sensitive areas you know what I'm
saying and when you have uh after the
gym stanky sometimes yeasty sensitive
area what do you want to do you want to
find a deodorant that is not only safe
but also very delicious and this right
here is tangerine and they design it so
you can put it all over your body from
neck to hole you know what I'm saying
and for me I feel
like it smells so good I could eat that
up and I can eat this for dessert but
not only that when you get this
wonderful starter kit it comes with the
whole body deodorant in this liquid form
here it's pretty nice this one's
lavender cream and you could also choose
two other things and what I decided to
get is these whites and this yummy yummy
right here acidified body wash so I
could smell good in the shower and I
know a lot of guys out there go to the
market and they're like man there's all
these products ah I'm just going to
stick to rinsing with water
but you know what this is the reason why
girls don't love you and you're
miserable and your family doesn't want
to hang out with you during Christmas
but look no further now you are going to
be a social dream and everybody is going
to nonstop smell your neck like you are
the most delicious person on Earth new
customers get $5 off Lumi starter pack
with our exclusive code and for a
limited time returning customers can get
$5 off their next purchase of $30 or
more use code OTR lumid deodorant.com l
u m e d e o d o r a n t do get it now
and smell fresher than fresh every kid
in the world that wears a basketball sh
play basetball like my white dick got
old dick like that that's the language I
speak yeah but it's it's really wide but
it's really small that's fine women like
the
you go scientifically proven I [__]
doubt that in Nick's world you go
Rainbow sandals every dude that chokes
dudes out
walking necklace they're choking
everybody out no but I think that yeah
I'm not saying Jiu-Jitsu guys got Style
but every Jiu-Jitsu dude's rocking
rainbow sandals really a lot I got the
Hawaiian ones the olaa same idea I like
those oh if you go like local brand yeah
that works I like those ones those are
the best flip flops cuz they [__]
they've lasted me forever how about
Redwing boots red wi boots that's
[__] gangster what about La lights
yeah yeah the light heels Jack while
you're at it righty you know what's
really you know it's a popular shoe I
see a lot of ladies wear is [__] uh
Blazers yo yeah Blazers got crazy old
Tik
Tok just cuz it's flat kids get wrecked
for wearing Shacks huh yeah for sure do
you guys remember Tony Hawks brand the
bones one that was such a cool it was
like a wannabe Converse and it was like
a high top and it was called like Bones
and [__] and then the logo was a [__]
bone guy going like this out bone bird I
remember his logo I think so yeah he had
high tops it was like Converse it was so
cool but I couldn't find it in my size
Tony Hawk killing again hey what shoe is
something that you [__] like oh I
love these these are I don't like my my
Jordan eights cuz they're rare like and
then the other thing like all these kids
are like just getting into sneakers and
I'm a little bit of a gatekeeper like I
just don't like culture vultures just
like like what you like what's culture
vulture like trying to beer not even
trying to be black like if you're going
to like Jordans you should like no
basketball yeah like watch Jordan play
or or you can just like no I like these
sneakers but just be straight up about
it so like Tik Tok kids will just wear
like only Jordan 1es or only Jordan 3's
and think everything else is stupid so
then I kind of like all the other ones
cuz all these kids Jordan Ones are
pretty dope though yeah Jordan Ones are
like a dunk they're just so kids right
now they be wearing [__] vintage
shirts and [__] they and I'll be like oh
[__] you like train spotting and they're
like what is that and I'm like that's on
your shirt it's a movie uh you don't
know what it is they're like nah I like
the design right where the beauty and
vintage stuff is that you can wear stuff
that we grew up actually enying so I buy
a Star Wars shirt cuz it's the best
movie ever and you wear a star war shirt
I've always felt intimidated by Jordan
3s which one are Jordan 3 uh I so I'm
impartial one I think they're one of the
best Silhouettes and two they came out
the year I was born what is a silhouette
uh like just a little you know like a
regular silhouette like silhouette of a
sneaker okay what is that oh yeah yeah
those are cool yeah they're just I just
don't think I think they're cool for me
i' seen those no Anthony would crush
those oh wait I don't think I could wear
Jordan high top you couldn't pull those
off no way so Jordan 3 some of the old
school high tops are cool cuz they're
kind of like uh not super high cuz when
you're short high tops are rough it's
meant to be worn with shorts that go
down to your ankles oh I love that some
jenko je what's your dream shoe you
dream shoe so there's only like [__]
100 pairs but they came out with the uh
the mcfli from oh yeah it's kind of like
yeah it's like a Holy Grail the shoes
[__] sick it cost like half a million
dollars you can't get them no and they
self they're self-tying right no I
literally think they're like Tech like
that yeah I have the other Tech ones the
hyper flies I have those and same thing
I don't know why the [__] I would ever
wear them yeah €50,000 wait you have the
do you have the back of the future shoe
they called the hyperfly 50,000 what is
that like 70,000 or something 7,000 a
knockoff like they they made a knockoff
dude you know what shoe I loved I loved
the the Kobes bro yeah all the Kobes are
hot right now and it's just like
especially like the later generation
ones but four five 4 five 6 78 yeah I I
used my favorite pair I got the Bruce
Lee ones the the eights those are
[__] dope I don't think Bart saw that
I was going to try to find a a
affordable pair and get them for Bart
yeah I have the [__] slashes from I
still have them bro those are like
$1,000 but okay so but now you can't
find any of them anywhere cuz they
stopped making them right and it's just
such a bummer because those were my
favorite aesthetic looking shoes and
they're comfy I played in those a lot
what do you think about guys that wear f
g I don't even know what that is yeah I
don't know fash yeah it's like a dress
Sho yeah that's Way Beyond me they light
up like that dude those are like 1,500
bucks yeah they charge it V cuz they're
self Laing it don't matter um the really
cool thing about it like my boy John
gave some to his dop ex almost
father-in-law ex-girlfriend's um Dad and
because he's got like carpal tunnel and
stuff like that so it's hard for him to
tie shoelaces oh that's cool yeah so
like when you think about like the
purpose of it outside of just like cool
fashion culture something like that and
like somebody who like has a hard time
tying shoelaces being able to step in
the shoe and itself self lacing like
[__] type type in uh Kobe Bruce Le to
show Bart oh yeah I didn't know tin
didn't design the first one he didn't
design the first three did he start
designing Jordan I think five maybe even
yeah I don't know I got the
11s so working with him isn't that crazy
or good then nah he sucks no he
revolutionized [__] the entire thing
got and on the back the I just got the U
I got my boy the the all white Kobe
proos I try to get him I tried I got him
for his birthday those are like the last
part I really want to get uh they're
coming out with the all black ones oh
Mambo ones so yeah shout out to my boy
Sebastian who works for me he he snagged
the Mambo ones that came out they came
out with the Kobe Bryant shoe for his
daughter he got those I was with you I
think I think we were at alphaland that
early morning workout I was on my phone
me and bar working out like get the my
phone like this yeah and then of course
my little homie gets some and I don't
all what did Doc Martin say about people
to you doc Mar are kind of on a dope
comeback that's like I think they're
sexy on I think they're sexy on they're
[__] dope they're good shoe good
quality sexy on dudes too I I got three
pairs no they're cool sty collab boots
baby that's you're going to jump
somebody is good thick Souls bro thick
Souls yeah if you got the right jeans
and [__] yeah those are dope you're
either a skin head racist or you're
someone that just likes to
party that's it you can't be I'll stick
to the party one then I guess you can't
be a rock man or nothing the cool thing
about having a bigger collection is if
you don't wear them out then when things
go out of style but then when they come
back in you still have the sh bro I
swear Jordans weren't cool like eight
years ago yeah or the Kobes the Kobes
that you have I had those and I just
played in them yeah yeah yeah same yeah
I ruined them cuz I played in them same
[__] 20 years ago I had Ninja Turtle
shoes and they weren't cool then and now
I got told that quite a bit do they look
like turtle shells cloggy looking I get
Mart and [__] I got some new [__] Doc
Martin deal hey what's your favorite
joint right now Anthony Le what kind of
shoes you I'm most excited for a shoe
I've been waiting for [__] 6 months
to come in the mail it's the K collab
Adidas Samba Clarks they got the Clark
Soul that's fire 6 months so you're into
sneakers how come you they work slowly
yeah they probably liter put air even
one time I have to dance you don't wear
him here though he made you want me to
wear here I want to see we want to see
him in purpose have a comedian shoe how
come we never brought us any air
sessiones I think a comedian shoe would
just be a shoe with the toe open and
it's exposed that'd be sick
openable I was trying to buy some air
sessiones I couldn't find any yeah those
are sick yeah those do you guys have a
dream shoe right now oh those are cool
yeah those are fire that's kith Clark
and Adidas cab yeah looks like an Adidas
shoe I don't care I don't
care whatever we're just trying to
represent ourselves you know we're
trying think SE you're doing it with woo
we respect it we always give you props
yeah I love that woo but mine's all one
of one [__] you guys is all [__]
Normy ass [__] but it's like one of 500
that's not Normy is it one of 500 no but
a few the M probably are the funny thing
about like the shoe scene it's it's only
it only impresses other people in it and
then people that aren't in it they're
like what the [__] is that they're
haters I'm not hating I feel like even
just being in LA like remember the off
FES where they have all these crazy tags
and [__] on the side people like what
the [__] you didn't take the tag off I I
actually like shoes so I I actually yeah
it's fun I like it more La people are
into it than even NorCal like s like a
lot of people aren't really into it now
more so but growing up not a lot of
people are into sneakers I always
thought NorCal was like sneaker head
Central especially like Oakland and San
Francisco but a lot of that dude when I
was in high school the all they wore is
Vans got my Vans on but they look like
sneakers always stand by Vans yeah Vans
right yeah you can't miss my parents are
so cheap that growing up I was taught
not to like brand things because we
can't afford them but then once I get
older I'm like wait the brand shit's way
[__] better you guys were just lying
to me so I didn't want them but they're
way better like I got Steve madens like
for dress shoes and like change your
life my my feet used to get cut up at
weddings and [__] and now it's like who
cares it's all good but I didn't know
but have you seen the 7-Eleven Crocs
though that's what I aspire to get there
are some Crocs the guy who basically put
Crocs on he was uh he just left Supreme
he was Supreme's creative director I
can't even if crazy hair yeah even if I
remembered his name I probably couldn't
say about the echos the echo clog ones
those ones the one that kind of look
like Kanye he makes them now yeah yeah
yeah but he was like the first one to do
a collab with them in like 2017 to set
CR off uh or Emory
Emory founded by oh
no the best shoe hands down it's the
most functional shoe you guys are all
wrong you're wrong yeah it might be TR
I'm a real gamer dude you don't have a
right to even [__] you know what I like
about Crocs though you can cross streams
and then it protects your feet from the
rocks and then when you get out of the
stream the water just comes out yeah bro
where I live we have
roads sometimes you go on a hike dude
they don't wear like hiking boots you're
going to soak your hiking boots in the
Stream hopefully my boots are made for
that [__] it's called hiking boots I why
woulding Crocs with holes in it kind of
like a Croc but it's like more of a
sport shoe and I was in them I was
letting my feet in the water it felt so
nice dude I was walking in rocks streams
dirt you're Slip Sliding around in the
Crocs like with your sweaty feet too no
dude no [__] way you like Tas I like
teas I like teas I'd rather go there
than Croc probably you're wrong though
sand you're wrong mys are for old ladies
get them dude get them get them they I
don't have a foot fetish but I like
shoes on women Sho I wear I wear 13 I'm
going to get you a size 13 Croc and you
have to wear it you go socks and a Croc
I go socks I go no socks I do [__]
ankle sock the more Clowny it might get
though yeah they look great mattero he's
6'4 he he won't look like n dude hey it
doesn't cut your feet it cuts my feet up
when I wear with no socks SC me once you
get a pair of Crocs you're going to get
so much puss dude
it's puss bro yeah so much pretty down I
need more these chicks away from talk
about Crocs you guys are all wrong Crocs
are the best I love
[Laughter]
[__]